Vamos a ver, yo no no voy a usar ningún argumento mío
para ver qué pasa con esto.
Yo utilizaré argumentos solamente de personas del Zoe.
Está tan consolidado que se está negociando la amnistía
que podemos hablar desde Felipe González,
que también es verdad,
que acaba de decir hoy que está viejo
y que hizo cosas anticonstitucionales,
dijo hoy Pedro Sánchez.
El Presidente del gobierno ha dicho de
Felipe González que está viejo.
Bueno,
es 1 forma de discriminar a las personas por la edad.
Se llama Edo, edofobia.
De acuerdo,
y además que hizo cosas anticonstitucionales.
Vamos a pedirle qué hizo, que no lo sabía,
que había hecho cosas anticonstitucionales
de Alfonso guerra,
más todavía de Tomás Gómez,
más de leguina,
expulsado eh de bueno,
de Nicolás redondo, expulsado sin haberlo oído.
No soy yo el que está diciendo
que está negociando la amnistía,
no soy yo, que también
es persona con trayectoria política importante,
1 de ellos Presidente de gobierno durante 14 años
que no ha habido ninguno.
Otro de ellos vicepresidente, 14 años,
otro de ellos Presidente de Madrid
que ha sido expulsado porque todos piensan.
Calculo que tendrán datos
de que se está negociando la amnistía,
habiendo quitado 2 delitos, ya
que es más grave,
con lo cual tiene carta blanca porque el 1,6%
de los españoles,
tan representado,
el 1,6 tiene porque tiene votos,
el que menos voto ha sacado en Cataluña,
ellos y con eh, ellos y izquierda republicana
Han sacado menos votos Que el PP,
o sea en su tierra, castigados como ninguno,
¿que es Cataluña
y eh? Porque la ley electoral
le permite tener los votos que tiene
y quien hoy son necesarios,
está intentando
con 1 mando a distancia sentado water club,
llevar este país donde el sistema oportuno